what we're going to do in this video is
think about a way to measure angles and
there's several ways to do this you
might have seen this leveraging things
like degrees in other videos but now
we're going to introduce a new concept
or maybe you know this concept but
another way of looking at this concept
so we have this angle ABC and we want to
think about what is a way to figure out
a measure of angle ABC now one way to
think about it would be well this angle
subtends some arc in this case it
subtends arc a c and we could see if
this angle were smaller if it's measure
were smaller it would subtract the
length of that arc would be smaller and
if the angle were wider or had a larger
measure if it looks something like that
then the arc length would be larger so
should we define the measure of an angle
like this as being equal to the length
of the arc that it subtends are these is
this a good measure well some of you
might immediately see a problem with
that because this length the length of
the arc that is subtended is not just
dependent on the angle the measure of
the angle it also depends on how big of
a circle you're dealing with if the
radius is larger then you're gonna have
a larger arc length for example let me
introduce another circle here so we have
the same angle measure the central angle
right over here you could say angle ABC
is still the same but now it's obtains a
different arc in these two different
circles you have this arc right over
here let's call this arc D E and the
length the length of Arc de is not equal
to the length of AC and so we can't
measure an angle just by the length of
the arc that it subtends if that angle
is the central angle in a circle so we
can get rid of that equality here but
what could we do well you might realize
that these two
heis that i just created you could kind
of say pi ABC and pi d b e these are
similar pies now we're not used to
talking in terms of similar pies but
what does it mean to be similar well you
have similarity if you can map one thing
onto another one shape onto another
through not just rigid transformations
but also through dilations and in this
situation if you were to take pi ABC and
just dilate it by a scale factor larger
than one there's some scale factor where
you would dilate it out to pi d b e and
what's interesting about that is if two
things are similar that means the ratio
between corresponding parts are going to
be the same so for example the ratio of
the length of Arc AC to segment the
length of segment B C is going to be
equal to the ratio of the length of Arc
de de to the length of segment B so
maybe this is a good measure maybe this
is a good measure for an angle and it is
indeed a pleasure that we use in
geometry and trigonometry and throughout
mathematics and we call it the Radian
measure of an angle of an angle and it
equals equals the ratio of the arc
length subtended by that angle
to the radius we just saw that in both
of these situations so let's see if we
can make this a little bit more tangible
let's say we had a circle here and it
has a central point let's just call that
point you know F and then let me create
an angle here and actually I can make a
right angle so let's call it f and
unless you call this point G and let's
call this H and let's say that the
radius over here is 2 meters and now
what would be the length of the arc
subtended by angle G F H well it's going
to be 1/4 the circumference of this
entire circle the way that I've drawn it
so the entire circumference I could
write here the circumference is going to
be equal to 2 pi times the radius which
is going to be 2 pi times 2 meters it's
going to be 4 pi meters and so if this
arc length is 1/4 of that this is going
to be pi meters and so based on the this
arc length and this radius what is going
to be the measure of angle G F H in
radians well we could say the measure of
angle G F H in radians is going to be
the ratio between the length of the arc
subtended and the radius and so it's
going to be PI meters over 2 meters the
meters you could view those as
cancelling out which equals PI over 2
and PI over 2 what well we would say
this is equal to PI over 2 radians now
one thing to think about is why do we
call it radians
it seems close to the word radius and
one way to think about it is when you
divide this length by the length of the
radius you figure out how many of the
radii is equivalent to the arc length in
question so for example in this
situation
one radii would look something like this
if you took the same length and you just
went around like this so you can see
it's going to be one point something
radii and that's why you could also say
it's one point something radians if you
took pi divided by two you're going to
get a little bit over one you're gonna
get one point and oh seven something